Praise should not begin with the phrase, "You da..." as in, "You da man."
Ending an expression of praise with the phrase, "and stuff" nullifies the praise.
Ending an expression of praise with the phrase, "Now get back to work!"...
...also nullifies the praise.
In ascending order of forcefulness:
E-mail, face-to-face conversation, handwritten note, bear hug.
No bear hugs.
A handwritten note is worth more than $100 gift card.
But probably not a $200 gift card.
Easy on superlatives:...
...hardest working, most glorious, awesomest, best smelling.
Praise followed by criticism is not praise.
Praise followed by praise is probably a little too much praise.
Praise followed by criticism followed by praise is a sandwich.